what's it mean to be a Texan to you
I've recently moved to Austin Texas
some uh two years in all right all right
welcome what's it mean to be a text
educators
Texas is about independence
politically Texas is not about
Republican or Democrat it's about
independence
independence of spirit sovereignty
uh
Texas
is about exploration one of the things I
love about Texas is I run into so many
Texans around the world
Texans are taught to go
b-tech conservative learn your learn
learn Who We Are
then go
go explore Pioneer Journey
and hopefully you come on back
with some goods and some stories are you
texting
and underneath that is this kind of um
freedom of
being an individual in the in the full
meaning of that word yeah well Texas is
liberal on your entrance
very liberal on your entrance
less regulation hey welcome High trust
High trust sir Welcome to our state come
on in yes yes yes
but
if you like cheats deal yeah
yeah we're conservative on our
consequences